[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
[Musik]
heftiger Raketenbeschuss in der Ukraine
bei seinem Besuch in Kiew sichert
Finanzminister Lindner dem Land weitere
Hilfe zu
Schreckmoment in 2500 Metern Höhe nach
einer Panne des regierungsfliegers
strandet Außenministerin beerburg in Abu
Dhabi
und ungesunder Lebensstil wir sitzen
immer länger im Schnitt mehr als 9
Stunden pro Tag und bewegen uns zu wenig
seit fast eineinhalb Jahren wehrt sich
die Ukraine gegen die russischen
Angriffe letzte Nacht waren sie wieder
besonders heftig dringend bittet
Deutschland das Waffensystem Taurus zu
liefern
Finanzminister lindner war heute
erstmals seit Kriegsbeginn vor Ort
Zusagen gab er keine nur dass er auf
baldige Klärung hoffe Claudia Weiler
berichtet
nach langer Fahrt und wohl kurzer Nacht
kommt Finanzminister Lindner morgen in
Kiew an empfangen wird er vom neuen
deutschen Botschafter in der Ukraine die
deutsche Unterstützung für Lindner nicht
nur eine Frage der Solidarität hier
werden auch unsere Werte verteidigt hier
geht es um die Zukunft der europäischen
friedens- und freiheitsordnung insgesamt
jedes Foto hier steht für einen
gefallenen Soldaten
dieser Gang gemeinsam mit dem
ukrainischen Vize Verteidigungsminister
berührt Lindner sehr sagt er selbst weil
er das Leid konkret mache zum Zeichen
der Anerkennung liegt der Blumen nieder
und trifft anschließend aktive Soldaten
hört den Wunsch nach weiteren
luftabwehrsystemen vom Typ ihres Team
Kiews Bürgermeister Klitschko fragt
konkret nach Taurus Marschflugkörpern
die Antwort eher weniger konkret da ich
weiß dass viele für eine solche
Unterstützung Sympathie haben wie ich
selbst auch hoffe ich auf eine baldige
sehr baldige Klärung dieser Frage als
finanz Minister verspricht Lindner
weitere Hilfen 22 Milliarden Euro hat
Deutschland schon zugesagt für
geflüchtete und Militärhilfen die
Ukraine sie bleibt abhängig man sei für
2024 im Dialog betonte ukrainische
Finanzminister und sagte in der
Pressekonferenz eine schwierige Zeit
voraus denn auch die Kosten für den
Wiederaufbau sie steigen Tag für Tag die
Zerstörung geht weiter in Odessa brennt
ein Supermarkt nieder herabfallende
Splitter eine abgewehrten Rakete sind
Schuld drei Menschen werden verletzt die
Hafenstadt im Süden seit dem Ende des
getreideabkommens ist sie immer öfter
Ziel von Angriffen
unsere Reporterin eine Brühl ist in
Odessa wie habt ihr die Angriffe in der
Nacht erlebt
den ersten Luftalarm den gab es kurz vor
Mitternacht danach danach folgten drei
heftige Angriffswellen die wir im Bunker
verbracht haben wir haben dort hier in
der Innenstadt immer wieder heftige
Explosionen gehört auch gehört wie die
ukrainische Luftabwehr arbeitet das
Problem dieser herunterstürzenden
Trümmerteile ist wirklich groß weil es
ja hier sehr große Brände in der ganzen
Stadt verursacht hat überall sind auch
Fensterscheiben kaputt gegangen und auch
das ist ein Problem denn viele Häuser
haben keinen Keller oder keinen Bunker
in denen die Menschen sich flüchten
können
wie ist die militärische Lage
einzuschätzen
in den letzten Tagen verstetigen sich
hier die sehr leichten Erfolgsmeldungen
von Seiten der Ukraine da ist von
Vorstößen an der südlichen Front die
Rede vom übersetzen über den Fluss nibro
Geländegewinne auch um bachmut wo
Präsident selenski heute seine Truppen
besucht hat dass es sicherlich als
Signal nach innen zu werten
Dankeschön an der Brühl live aus Odessa
nach Deutschland in den kommenden
Monaten sei keine Belebung der
Wirtschaft in Sicht das sagt heute das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium mit Blick
auf die neuesten Zahlen zu Produktion
Exporten und Aufträgen der Bundeskanzler
Klang da gestern im ZDF sommerinterview
optimistischer aber wie sehen die Firmen
selbst ihre Lage Peter Wagner war bei
einem Unternehmen in Hessen
das Unternehmen Oculus stellt den
Wetzlar und weltweit mit über 700
Beschäftigten optische Spezialgeräte her
Messinstrumente für Augenärzte und
Optiker im Minen und Ausland Firmenchef
kirchhübl ist von den Aussagen des
Kanzlers zur Wirtschaftslage enttäuscht
die hochwertige Wertschöpfung die wir
hier am Standort haben die Anlagen die
da stehen die schaffen Steuern hier und
wenn man die weg ekeln durch so
Energiepreise wie das was wir uns hier
gerade erlauben ja dann
gibt's keine Transformation da gibt's
kein Klimaschutz mehr Christian
Kirchhügel fordert niedrige und
international wettbewerbsfähige
Energiepreise flächendecken nicht nur
für die Industrie auch Ökonomen und
Wirtschaftsverbände sehen aktuelle
erhebliche Standort Nachteile für die
Unternehmen
Deutschland fällt im Wettbewerb zurück
via hatten mal durchschnittliche
Unternehmenssteuersätze jetzt sind wir
ein Hooks höchststeuerland unsere
Bürokratiekosten sind auch im
internationalen Vergleich sehr hoch und
in der Digitalisierung läuft mir
hinterher in unseren Umfragen zeigt sich
das immer mehr Unternehmen überlegen
Produktion ins Ausland zu verlagern und
das aus Kostengründen im Moment beginnt
diese Bewegung und Politik ist gut
beraten sich hier mit Reformen zu
engagieren damit daraus kann
Flächenbrand wird was sind
unternehmerland auf Land ab das Leben
besonders schwer macht ist die
ausufernde Bürokratie egal ob wir im
Bereich der Bauvorschriften sind ob wir
im Bereich des Arbeitsrechts hin oder im
Bereich medizinische Regulierung die MDR
überall haben wir viel zu viele
Regularien am Start die leider Gottes
Zukunft verhindern anstatt schaffen
Fazit des Unternehmers Kanzler und
Bundesregierung haben noch nicht
ausreichend verstanden wie ernst die
Lage in der deutschen Wirtschaft
ist
in ZDF heute live diskutiert gleich
Professoren Malmendier sie ist Mitglied
der deutschen Wirtschaftsweisen und
Professoren in den USA um 19:30 Uhr in
der heute App und auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen
entwicklungsministerin Schulze ist zu
einer mehrtägigen Reise nach Afrika in
die seilzone aufgebrochen
Auftakt war heute in Mauretanien neben
der wirtschaftlichen Zusammenarbeit geht
es auch um die schwierige Lage nach dem
Putsch in Niger der Westen und viele
afrikanische Staaten fordern die
Wiedereinsetzung des gestürzten
Präsidenten jedoch hat die Militär
herunter jetzt angekündigt war Zoom
wegen hochverratsvor Gericht stellen zu
wollen darauf kann die Todesstrafe
verhängt werden
eigentlich wollte Außenministerin
Anna-Lena baerbock jetzt in Australien
sein doch nach einem Tankstopp in Abu
Dhabi gab es ein technisches Problem mit
dem regierungsflieger nicht zum ersten
Mal 2018 hatte der Luftwaffen Airbus
Konrad Adenauer eine Panne die damalige
Kanzlerin Merkel flog dann Berlin jetzt
zum G20 Gipfel nach Buenos Aires die
Probleme werfen die Frage auf wie
zuverlässig sind die Maschinen der
Flugbereitschaft wenn Ihr hierher
vergangene Nacht regierungsflieger A340
hat aufgetankt in Abu Dhabi plötzlich
bekommen Außenministerin Werbung und die
begleitende Presse folgende Sätze des
Kapitäns zu hören das Flugzeug muss
umkehren
unterschiedlich ganz so gut Neuigkeiten
heute ist es passiert was ich bisher
noch nicht kenne eben sowas aber
Simulator eine Klappe die zum Start
ausgefahren war ließ sich nicht wieder
einfahren die Folge zu geringe
Geschwindigkeit und Flughöhe ein
Mitreisender ZDF Korrespondent erlebt
das an Bord mit
es wird aber auch nicht sofort wieder
landen weil die Maschine dafür zu schwer
war eben weil gerade erst vollgetankt
worden war dann mussten 80 Tonnen
Kerosin erstmal rausgesprüht werden und
erst danach nach und anderthalb Stunden
konnte dann hier zum zweiten Mal die
Landung erfolgen
der regierungsflieger ist nun schon fast
25 Jahre im Dienst
ein Abu Dhabi zum Beispiel wäre die
große Basis der dortigen
Fluggesellschaft hat und die hat ein
problemlos Ersatzteile liefern können
wenn die Luftwaffe ein moderneres
Flugzeug ihre A350 diese ja auch bereits
fliegen am Boden hat mit einem Problem
nicht die erste Panne dieses Fliegers
Angela Merkel musste mal Linie zum
G20-Gipfel nach Argentinien fliegen
Verteilerbox kaputt bei einer Reise von
Olaf Scholz wurden mal Kabel von
Nagetieren angeknabbert die
Bundesregierung aber sieht keine
Altersschwäche beim regierungsflieger
beim Flugzeug ist der Wartungszustand
das entscheidende und nicht das Alter
und diese Flugzeuge werden so gewartet
dass sie mit jedem neuen Flugzeug
vergleichbar sind was ihre Sicherheit
angeht trotzdem bringen sie die Politik
nicht immer pünktlich zur Arbeit
weitergeht noch offen
der deutsche Journalistenverband rät
Medienschaffenden weder beruflich noch
privat in die Türkei zu reisen der
Verband reagiert damit auf die
vorübergehende Festnahme der Linken
Bundestagsabgeordneten
Akbulut bei ihrer einreiseanfang August
dies habe gezeigt dass Präsident Erdogan
Kritiker als militante Staatsfeinde
betrachtet und verfolgt wenn dazu die
Möglichkeit besteht
vor genau fünf Jahren stürzte ihn Genua
nach heftigen Regenfällen die
morandi-brücke ein 43 Menschen starben
dutzende Häuser und Fahrzeuge wurden
unter den Trümmern der Autobahnbrücke
begraben das Unfassbare an der Tragödie
Menge an dem Bauwerk waren schon seit
Anfang der 90er Jahre bekannt heute
erinnerten Angehörige der Opfer und
Regierungsvertreter an das Unglück die
neue Brücke war nach nicht mal zwei
Jahren Bauzeit fertig
der bayerische
afd-landtagskandidat Andreas Jurka ist
nach eigenen Angaben in Augsburg
gewaltsam angegriffen und verletzt
worden die Polizei bestätigte der
35-Jährige habe am Samstagmorgen den
Notruf gewählt und gesagt zwei
Unbekannte hätten ihn geschlagen die
Kripo ermittelt und bitte Zeugen sich zu
melden
mit Schwung und Optimismus ins neue
Schuljahr starten das ist allen zu
wünschen die jetzt nach und nach aus den
Sommerferien kommen ausgebremst werden
viele durch die alten Probleme überall
fehlen Lehrer und Lehrerinnen besonders
an schwierigen Standorten nRW will jetzt
mehr Lehre an bestimmte Schulen ins
Ruhrgebiet beordern Thaddäus Parade
berichtet
Freiarbeit für eine Gruppe von Kindern
der dritten Klasse in der
Gemeinschaftsgrundschule
Kurt-Schumacher-Straße in Gelsenkirchen
fast alle hier sind Ausländer oder haben
einen Migrationshintergrund und die
meisten von ihnen starten bei der
Einschulung mit Defiziten beobachten Sie
hier
das heißt diese Kinder bringen wenig
Basiskompetenzen mitbringen so gut wie
keine Sprache oft mit keine deutsche
Sprache so zusammengefasst sind die
meisten unserer Kinder auf einem Niveau
eines dreijährigen wenn sie zur Schule
kommen hier im größten Ballungsraum der
Republik ist auch der größte
pädagogische Brennpunkt 31% der
Grundschulen im Ruhrgebiet liegen in
Vierteln die von Armut geprägt sind nur
wenige Lehrer wollen hier arbeiten viele
Stellen bleiben unbesetzt auch zwei an
der Grundschule in Gelsenkirchen das ist
oft ein Problem also ich kann da nur
alle auffordern zu sagen das ist eine
tolle Arbeit die wir machen und die
macht sehr viel Spaß weil wir das Gefühl
haben und auch Erfolge sehen was zu
bewegen die NRW Landesregierung hat
Maßnahmen ergriffen ein Sozialindex
ermittelt den Förderbedarf von Schulen
außerdem werden Lehrer zeitlich
befristet ins Ruhrgebiet abgeordnet
nicht genug sagen Bildungsexperten und
fordern für NRW eine zentrale Vergabe
der Personalstellen wie z.B in Bayern
für die Frage von Bildungsgerechtigkeit
und bildungsversorgung ist natürlich
eine staatliche Entscheidung die von
oben gesteuert wird vor allen Dingen in
solchen Zeiten indem wir knappen Lehrer
Verfügbarkeit haben eigentlich die
günstigere Steuerungswirkung mehr
Lehrkräfte mehr finanzielle
Unterstützung und mehr frühkindliche
Bildung das braucht es um schlechter
gestellten Schulen und Schülern bei der
Integration zu helfen
blicken wir auf die Insel Maui im
US-Bundesstaat Hawaii dort ist die Zahl
der Toten nach den verheerenden wald-
und Buschbränden auf 96 gestiegen noch
immer werden viele Menschen vermisst
mittlerweile hat die Feuerwehr die
meisten Brände unter Kontrolle derweil
wächst die Kritik an der späten Warnung
und der Reaktion der Behörden mit
Gottesdiensten und Andachten erinnern
familienaufbau an die Opfer für die
Überlebenden werden auf der ganzen Insel
Hilfspakete gepackt
in Norditalien westlich von Turin haben
Unwetter am Sonntagabend große Schäden
angerichtet nach schweren Regelfällen
kam es zu Erdrutschen und einer
Schlammlawine in der Gemeinde warnonetia
Wasser und Schlamm durchfluteten dabei
die Straßen des Dorfes Autos wurden
mitgerissen und 120 Menschen mussten in
Sicherheit gebracht werden sechs
Personen konnten gerettet werden nachdem
ihr Wohnmobil von der Schlammlawine
erfasst wurde
es ist kein besonders schmeichlerhaftes
Ergebnis wir verbringen immer mehr Zeit
im Sitzen im Durchschnitt über 9 Stunden
pro Tag so steht's in einem Report der
deutschen Krankenversicherung und der
Sporthochschule Köln das viele sitzen
ist schlecht für die Gesundheit aber und
das ist die gute Nachricht Abhilfe
schaffen es ganz einfach Carsten bärend
auf geht's
sitzen ist vorbei jetzt geht's in die
aktive Pause danke Schönfelder ist
Fitnesstrainerin in Berlin mit ihren
Firmentrainings will sie die
Hauptstädter von ihren Bürostühlen holen
[Applaus]
das Problem beim Sitzen ist dass der
komplette untere Bereich die Beine im
Prinzip am Becken abwärts alles
abgeschaltet wird laut aktuellem DKV
Gesundheitsreport verbringen die
deutschen jeden Tag 9,2 Stunden im
sitzen im Auto im Büro und zu Hause das
ist eine halbe Stunde mehr als während
der Pandemie 2021 ja letztendlich so das
ist ein riesiger Faktor ist der aber
dazu führt dass ich viele Krankheiten
einstellen wie Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankung
Stoffwechselerkrankungen wie Diabetes
Beispiel oder das Thema Übergewicht
insofern heißt es ja ohne das sitzen
würden viele dieser Probleme erst gar
nicht auftreten wenn ihr Schmerzen habt
Verspannungen Kopfschmerzen und Stress
all das soll der Mix aus dreching und
einfachen Kraftübungen lindern also wenn
ich diese Übung aktiv mache werde ich
größer und L
Ocker ich kann
dann wieder besser sitzen
Faustregel ist alle halbe Stunde für
zwei Minuten sich zu bewegen das heißt
eine einzige Übung zu machen
zwischendurch sich einmal aufzudehnen zu
stretchen den Körper in die richtige
Körperhaltung wieder zurückzubringen das
ist die Lösung statt Dauer sitzen
einfach mal aufstehen und den Körper in
Schwung bringen das geht nicht nur im
Büro sondern auch vor dem Fernseher
jawohl ja gesund leben die Studie hat da
viel Interessantes zu bieten zum
Beispiel welche Rolle spielt das Gehalt
für die Gesundheit wo leben die
gesündesten Menschen in Deutschland
alles nachzulesen in der ZDF heute App
und jetzt zur Fußball-WM Endspurt ist da
Norbert die Halbfinale und keines der
vier Teams hatte bislang den Titel
geholt Australien und England nicht
ebenso wenig wie Spanien und Schweden
die morgen Vormittag in Auckland den
Auftakt machen ja und die bei dem WM
Turnier mit starken Auftritten überzeugt
haben
gefühlt sei es ein Endspiel so die
Aussage der Spanierinnen bei der
abschlusspk noch nie sind sie bei einer
WM so weit gekommen und zeigten beim 2:1
gegen die Niederlande deutlich dass sie
in der Weltspitze mithalten können
vergessen scheint die Revolte gegen
Trainer Frau wilder vor knapp einem Jahr
Ziele schweißen zusammen Erfolge erst
recht das Halbfinale gegen Schweden das
Japan mit 2:1 entzauberte wird
allerdings ein harter Brocken noch nie
konnte eine spanische Frauen
Nationalmannschaft gegen eine
schwedische gewinnen aber das ist nur
Statistik im Abschlusstraining waren
beide Teams fokussiert es wird wohl ein
hochspannendes Halbfinale auf Augenhöhe
ja freuen uns drauf Spanien gegen
Schweden morgen Vormittag live bei uns
im ZDF zu sehen ab
9:35 Uhr bei uns startet die erste
Fußball-Bundesliga der Männer ja am
Freitag in England rollt der Ball
bereits in der Premier League gestern
die Partie Liverpool gegen Chelsea für
die Reds von Trainer Jürgen Klopp reicht
es nur zu einem Unentschieden
Liverpools top Torjäger moosalava notte
museed als er nach 77 Minuten vom Platz
musste Spielstand da eins zu eins
verständlich denn die retzginge in der
18 minute nach einem brillanten Salat zu
Spiel auf Louis Dias in Führung
wenig später traf Salah auch noch selbst
das Tor zählte aber nicht
abseits Position
Chelsea blieb offensiv gefährlich der
Franzose Axel dieser i mit dem
verdienten Ausgleich nach 37 Minuten und
auch die Blusen noch mit einem
irregulären Treffer am Ende ein
glanzloses 1:1 für Jürgen Klopp beim
Liga Auftakt an der stemfort Bridge
nächster Rückschlag für das deutsche
Leichtathletik Team kurz vor der WM in
Budapest
Constanze Kloster helfen hier bei ihrem
EM-Sieg letztes Jahr über 5000 Meter
muss wegen fußproblem passen nach
Weitspringerin Malaika miambo
sperrwerfer Johannes Vetter und
Stabhochspringer wo kann der Liter wäre
ein weiterer prominenter Ausfall
selbst natürlich die Hoffnung des DVDs
zum Schluss noch eine besondere Ehrung
für unsere sechs wohl dienstältesten
Kollegen
Anton Berti Conny Depp Edi und Fritzchen
besser bekannt als die Mainzelmännchen
bekommen zum 60 Geburtstag eine eigene
briefmarkenserie die Sondermarken für
die Markenbotschafter des ZDF sind etwas
teurer als gewöhnlich wer mehr Erlös
fließt in Projekte für Kinder und
Jugendliche
der Deutsche Wetterdienst warnt aktuell
vor schweren Gewittern mit Starkregen in
Teilen Sachsens und auch morgen ist mit
schweren Gewittern zu rechnen mir hat
gleich aus dem Thermi das heute journal
mit Anne Gellinek um viertel vor zehn
einen schönen Abend eben noch und bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter genau über der
Mitte halten sich die Fronten dieses
Tiefs hier und dementsprechend gibt es
hier Schauer und Gewitter teilweise im
unwetterbereich aus dem Südwesten kommt
dazu noch warme teils heiße Luft in der
Nacht lösen sich hier und da schau und
gewisse auf aber neu kommen auch dazu
das ist der Front geschuldet die hier
quer drüber liegt ganz im Süden und im
Norden bleibt es trockene Temperatur und
kühlen kaum ab im Osten 20 Grad im
Südwesten auch das bedeutet hier und
dort gibt es eine tropische Nacht morgen
dann wieder quer über Deutschland als
heftige Gewitter im unwetterbereich mit
Starkregen Hagel und Sturmböen und dann
zum Abend und in der Nacht von den Alpen
heraus neue Gewitter im Süden die können
durchaus dann heftig ausfallende schwer
Gewitterlage ist dann wieder möglich
Temperaturen im Osten bei 33 Grad hier
eine extreme Wärmebelastung
31 im Südosten und am kühlsten noch mit
23 Grad Richtung Nordsee die nächsten
Tage bleibt diese Fronten Systeme diese
konnten Systeme über der Mitte hier
gibt's dann Schauer und Gewitter die
sich kaum bewegen 21 bis 31 am Mittwoch
und Freitag bis 33 ein schöner Abend